Let's go back to the sales leads data set that we reviewed earlier and demoed loading.
While there are many columns that are useful to the sales team,
we just need a few columns to be available for a bigger corporate forecasting projection.
We'll go ahead and delete customer names,
emails, gender, and any other fields that won't be useful.
For the purposes of this exercise,
I'm just going to go ahead and delete columns from the data set I don't need,
which will be most of these.
We'll just leave company, product name,
date of contact, and prospective sales.
Prospective sales and date of contact are right here.
If I look towards the beginning,
I can see company right here.
There are two ways I can go about deleting columns that I don't need.
Option 1 is to delete a small number of columns.
Say, I want to delete these first three.
I'm going to select them, what I did just now,
is I held down the shift key when I started with
prospective customer as I selected last name.
Then I'm just going to right-click and I'm going to remove the columns.
There we have our applied step right here.
As you can see,
they disappeared from the table.
The query that we're working in.
Option 2 is when you want to delete a high number of columns.
You select the columns you want to keep,
and then you choose the option to delete the other columns.
Here I'm going to hold down the control button and I'm going to
select company, product name,
which in this case is called product of interest,
then date of contact,
and prospective sales value.
I have those columns selected and I'm going to
right-click here and see how instead of remove columns,
there's another option that says remove other columns.
I'm going to click that.
All I have left are the five that I initially wanted, and somehow e-mail.
Right-click, select remove, delete just one column,
and here we are; company,
product of interest, date of contact, prospective sales, value.
Note that each time you make a change,
this lovely Applied Steps section continues to document each step.
If I wanted to remove them,
all I have to do is click right here,
and those columns that were part of that step for removal have popped right back.